Listening comprehension, as I've
said before, is the core skill
that leads us to speaking better.
Leads us to reading better.
Leads us to better, a better
sense of the language.
Hi there, Steve Kaufmann here and today,
I wanna talk about listening the most
powerful activity and language learning.
Remember if you enjoy my videos,
please subscribe, click on
the bell for notifications.
If you follow me on a podcast
service, please leave a comment.
So I've spoken a lot about listening, but
today I was reminded of how tremendously
powerful a learning activity it is.
I had to spend much of the day
cleaning up around the house.
We're donating some books and
other material to the thrift store
getting rid of a lot of garbage.
So I had to go to the recycling depot.
So there was a good an hour and
a half, two hours between working
and driving and I listened to my
Persian podcast Bplus podcast.
Now, first of all, what's powerful is
that I'm able to use all this time,
time that would otherwise be dead.
Second of all, uh, this Bplus podcast, uh,
this Ali Bandari, I think it is, he talks
about a variety of different subjects.
What's of interest to me
is the history of Iran.
So he talks about the Safavid Dynasty.
He talks about different Kings,
Shah of the Safavid Dynasty, Shah
Ismail, Shah Abbas, and so forth.
And of course, I have heard some of
this stuff before, but I get it again
in a slightly different context.
So I'm learning, not deliberately
learning, not taking notes, but
gradualy things are becoming
clearer to me through listening.
And I'm, I'm reminded of the fact
that throughout history for most of
recorded history, we had no writing.
People couldn't read
like, yes, the first...
I know one of the earliest, in fact,
examples of writing is, is this
writing on these clay cylinders?
And in fact, uh, Darius's famous, kind of
the, one of the first written documents
about human rights was, was written in
cuneiform script on these clay cylinders.
And, but if we go through history, you
know, the, again, going back to that
time, you know, the legend of Gilgamesh,
or, uh, the Odyssey or, or the, uh,
the Iliad or, uh, in, in south and
Southeast Asia, the Ramayana stories,
stories from China, from elsewhere.
People have had stories
and people listened.
It's just that they didn't have MP3
players and they listened more than once.
And we all have this as children.
We had our favorite stories and these...
in order for the, the Iliad the Ramayana
or any of these famous stories to be
passed on from generation to generation
people told these stories more than once.
And they were favorite stories
and people were happy to listen
to them over and over again.
And they enjoyed different aspects of
the story every time they listened.
And, and similarly, you know, as
I'm listening, as I said, in one
of my previous videos, I don't
deliberately try to understand.
And of course I lose
focus from time to time.
And I'm sure that, uh, children sitting
around at campfire, listening to a
story every so often they, you know,
look somewhere else and they lose
focus and then they come back to it.
It doesn't matter, but it's such a
powerful means of bringing knowledge
into your brain and it's it, it,
you know, evokes the the subject
in a way that video can't do.
Uh, I remember when I, uh, I got these,
uh, storytellers, Chinese storytellers
telling The Romance of the Three
Kingdoms and, uh, the man's voice and
the way he conjured up horses and dust,
I could almost smell the dust and see
the action, because it was all words.
And when I got to see a video of the same
story, It, it was a pale, uh, version
of the same, far less, uh, left to the
imagination, obviously fewer words.
So, so this listening is so powerful.
Uh, you'll see, on my, uh, shot of
my screen at LingQ that I've been,
you know, listening to these stories
and studying the text so that I
understand them a bit better each time.
Uh, but I've never looked...
and these are videos.
These are YouTube videos, and I'm sure
he shows a lot of stuff and pictures of
these, uh, Persian Kings and whatever.
But, uh, I just listen,
I just listen and read.
And so I have an image
incomplete, somewhat imperfect.
It doesn't matter.
My knowledge is accumulating.
Every time I listen, I, I
gather a few more words.
I get a different sense of these Kings
and their time and Isfahan and different
aspects of the history, the culture,
the geography of Iran and some words.
And it's all gradually
accumulating without any deliberate
effort on my, on my part.
But it's, it's, it's accumulating.
It's accumulating like, like ,you
know, uh, I've often used the image
in, in language running of this...
if you start rolling a snowball down a
hill, it'll gradually pick up more and
more snow and, and that's how it is.
And yet it's so portable.
It's so easy to do.
If I had to watch his videos, I would
have to sit down and watch them.
Uh, and I'm gonna do a video about
reading, which is powerful in its own
way, because it's a lovely environment
to get into just, you know, you and the
text, uh, without the sound, without
the audio, just you and the text.
That's also powerful, but reading
is something that has come
relatively lately to humans.
And, and in particular, the vast majority
of humans didn't read until about
the 15th, 16th, 17th, 18th century.
And so they relied on the spoken word.
They relied on familiar stories,
told over and over again, uh, as
a means of acquiring information
as a means of entertainment.
And we now can use that same, uh,
the wonder of storytelling as a
means of acquiring knowledge as a
means of acquiring, uh, language
as a form of entertainment.
And, uh, and of course the means of
delivering this have just proliferated.
So we have podcasts and we have,
uh, you know, audio books and
different services, podcast services.
Audiobook services.
And so this, this rich world where,
you know, it used to be that we'd
have to, uh, maybe sit in a, in a
room somewhere or sit outside, um,
underneath the trees to listen to
the storyteller spin his or her tale.
Very often a story that we were
familiar with in the olden days
and now we just carry that with us.
I mean, how many stories can I keep
in how many different languages, just
in my little iPhone and I can listen
to whichever one I wanna listen to.
I can even shuffle them and listen
to them in different orders.
I can go to different languages.
Uh, all of those things
are now available to us.
Uh, and I think so listening is not
only a very effective way of learning,
listening comprehension, as I've said
before, is the core skill that leads
us to speaking better, leads us to
reading better, leads us to better, a
better sense of the language, but it
is also a major form of entertainment.
It's a major form of enjoying the
language, particularly when we don't
have the opportunity to be surrounded
by people speaking the language.
There are so many means today
through technology whereby we can
access the language and enjoyment
and knowledge through listening.
And so, and, and another thing about
listening too, is it's kind of easy to do.
So it gets you going, uh, as
I've said before, very often the
main thing is to get started.
So even in terms of a day, you know, today
I had to do some chores around the house.
But I start listening now because
I've been listening and not
understanding a fair amount of it.
I am now my, my curiosity is piqued.
It triggers my reading and it
just keeps me going down the
path of learning the language.
So I just wanted, again, I wanted
to touch on this, the importance of
listening as the easiest thing you
can do in order to create the time and
push yourself forward in your language.
And I'll leave you a couple
of videos about listening
that I've done in the past.
And hopefully again, I
don't contradict myself.
Thank you for listening.
Bye for now.